john lester on the mound for saint louis
11 career starts
at busch stadium he's four and three
here's eduardo escobar the switch hitter
and on the first pitch he drives one
into right center that is gonna go to
the wall on a couple of bounces escobar
on his way to second with a two-out
double
let's hang it out well why take it right
right down the middle only 89 miles an
hour that's about all you're going to
get out of last three might touch 90
once in a while but not too often
a two-out double for escobar
sets up christian yelich
two-and-one the count and yell it's back
up the middle it hits lester he's down
yellich will reach on an infield hit and
that one stung him
the plant leg the right leg turns ever
so slightly yeah i got it right off the
shin well it's great to see john be able
to pop up walk around after this one
looks like it catches him just above the
ankle on that right leg
the 2-2 pitch
got him to reach for it taken there by
de young
and the brewers will strand a pair
and the numbers rock on brandon woodruff
they jump off the page yeah no kidding
turn to nash league an earned run
average he's seventh in strikeouts he's
second an opponent banning average at
182.
and that is hit the other way inside the
third base line
tommy edmond a leadoff double
02 mistake just up in the zone it's a
really nice piece of hitting by tommy
edmund sees it up recognizes it and
pulls the hands in and just shoots it
right down that third base line as
arenado strides to the plate
hit down the left field line and a fair
ball down into the corner aronado on his
way to second base edmund will score
and the cardinals lead it one to nothing
a pair of doubles here in the first no
check swing here it's a fastball in in
and he's able to pull the hands and get
to it look at that ball that ball is in
off the plate and nolan gets to it just
keeps it fair
it's a beautiful thing
get some momentum going your way some
good energy
escobar doubled to right center
ground ball backhanded arenado
wow
nolan arnauto what a play he knows he's
gonna have to get rid of this ball
quickly gets it on the backhand side
flat foot makes the strong throw to get
him
23 homers this season
ouch lester drills him
he was trying to bust him in on the last
pitch this one way in there and avi
garcia is hit by a pitch i thought you
might not hear much from maria's the
rest of the year
and then all of a sudden couldn't keep
him out of the lineup now he draws a
walk manny pina coming up he can slow it
down with the best of them lester
on the first pitch and that's fair
just off the outstretched arena's glove
garcia comes in to score urias will stop
at third and the pineapple with an rbi
double we're tied in one in the fourth
yeah there you go
manny pina is really starting to swing a
good bat starting to throw some power
another extra base hit for manny
and an rbi beats it in front of home
plate and just out of the reach of
marinado which is no easy task so two
men gone and back to the top of the
order colton wong
long slashes one down the line a base
hit and this is going to bring in two
runs uras and pina will score colton
wong with a 2 rbi single and it's 3-1
milwaukee in the fourth check it out
watch this front shoulder here that
front shoulder doesn't budge he gets it
down in a trademark a little bit but
able to fight it off down the line and
now a chance for the brewers to add on
here with adamus
two to the count
and adamus down the left field line
that's fair little jam shots gonna fall
long on his way to third now he's gonna
crank it up and head home here's the cut
off and relay and wong is in there
a high throw from the young
and cold wong
able to just sneak a foot in there that
throw is on to money wong's gonna be
an easy out at home plate
another good piece of hitting by the
brewers that's the moment he decided to
go right there he saw neil bobolitt
slowed down a little bit
and they would put on the after burners
a high throw that's why he's safe
yeah kisner had to jump
and the foot in there
well goldschmidt a 332 career hitter
against milwaukee
and that'll be a base hit tying run will
come to the play
goldie two for three tonight
oronata with a double grounded out to
third one for two
outfield deep
and that'll be a base hit
here comes kisner he will score cuts a
lead to four to two
the cardinals
get another hit from nolan oronado
another run batted in
and with that he is up to 80 and it's
4-2
tyler o'neill coming up with runners at
first and second the 2-2 pitch
o'neal with the drive
this one is way
out of hair
oh goodness he hugged it and the
cardinals go on top but a blast from
tyler o'neill
wow just a hanging breaking ball and
that is something that tyler o'neill
this 2021 version of tyler o'neil he
does not miss those things cardinals are
back the fans are back this place is
loud
bars nuke bar those aren't booze those
are newts
the one
newt bar
into right back to back
into the st louis bullpen
o'neill
now
nude bar
edmond is one out of three
doubled and scored in the first
that's lined into the gap in left center
yelich won't get there gets by him all
the way to the wall
dean will score edmond racing to third
and they hold them up at the last second
oh they thought about bringing them in
is that scooted by yelich and it adds to
the st louis lead 7-4
full count with the bases loaded and he
walked him three consecutive walks and a
bases loaded walk for harrison bader
the cardinals add to their lead to make
it eight to four
the one-two pitch
fly ball into center bader is there and
the cardinals will salvage a game in
this series
they win game three by the final of
eight to four as they come back in a
much needed win
you